[Musique]
depuis une semaine la coupe du monde de
football a débuté les enfants envie de
jouer même à l'intérieur pas de panique
mélanie a la solution pour vos vitres
vases et autres éléments fragiles en
smashant pour les protéger khemissi
jouent au baby-foot et même au mini baby
foot à faire de ses propres mains voila
moi c'est le mien je les fais un peu
plus avant l'émission alors il ya
environ 40 minutes de préparation mais
deux fois plus de plaisir de jouer après
pour le faire rien de plus simple une
boîte à chaussures des baguettes en bois
des pinces à linge des bouchons en liège
une règle et de la peinture alors pour
commencer j'ai peint le four ouvert de
la boîte on symbolise comme ça le
terrain ont fait de la peinture blanche
ou pourquoi pas du du correcteur avec
mon stylo il faut bien sûr calculé le
centre et sur les côtés de la boîte
dessiner les cages de but et les
découper moi j'ai choisi de prendre un
cutter et comme toujours en avait
l'habitude quand on utilise un objet
coupant
ou le fait qu'un adulte et sans oublier
le plus importante pour jouer il nous
faut des joueurs
évidemment oui qui sont ici les pinces à
linge alors deux équipes de couleur atv
78 sont les rouges qui affronte les jo
de penne bien trois passes de chaque
couleur et laissez les sécher on aime un
petit peu de côté si vous voulez pousser
la précision vous est des grands fans
pourquoi ne pas imprimer les visages de
vos joueurs préférés pour les coller au
dessus des pinces à linge et vous créez
votre propre équipe est là après on
arrive à l'étape un peu plus de
technique
un but technique c'est juste parce qu'il
faut prendre des mesures nous faut
utiliser la règle les pinces ne doivent
pas toucher le fond de la boîte
autrement pourra pas les bouger moi j'ai
fait l'erreur sur l'une d'entre elles il
a fallu refaire ensuite toujours clarey
ont fait les repères alain à l'extérieur
de la boîte de chaque côté et c'est là
que vous allez faire passer les vagues
est huit coups de cutter et vous pouvez
les insérer vous positionner bien les
pinces dessus alors si vous sentez
qu'elle tourne un peu parce qu'elles
sont parfois un peu plus large
un petit point de colle ou de la
peinture aussi quand ça sèche ça marche
très bien
les bouchons de liège sont là les
poignets la dernière étape et non des
moindres décorer la balle de ton pong
est joué merci mélanie on se fera un
petit match après 7,8 culture comprend
sept ans après généré qui ferait
vraiment rapport comme ça alors
merci beaucoup mélanie